Ron DeSantis is over playing his hand
with the anti-woke stuff and Ron
DeSantis is really overplaying his hand
with the anti-disney stuff and if you
think Dominion voting systems had good
attorneys representing them against Fox
News just wait until you see how good
Disney's attorneys are CNBC reports
Disney Sue's Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis alleges political effort to
hurt its business Walt Disney company
sued Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
alleging that the Republican Governor
has waged a quote Relentless campaign to
weaponize government power over the
company if we are to accurately and
correctly use the term weaponization
it's hard to think of a better example
than what Rhonda santis has done with
government power against Walt Disney
World as a retaliatory action for Walt
Disney World saying we're against the
don't say gay bill